[Música]
hola khan academy se basa en un sistema
de aprendizaje de dominio diseñado para
acelerar el progreso de los estudiantes
y ayudarlos a aprender practicar y
aplicar nuevas ideas y habilidades
queremos que cada alumno estudie no sólo
para aprobar exámenes sino también para
dominar el contenido y consolidar este
aprendizaje veamos como puedes usar
dominio de khan academy en tu salón de
clases
ah
selecciona una de tus clases en el menú
vertical haz clic en la pestaña dominio
de curso luego haz clic en establece
objetivos es posible elegir el curso que
deseas o asignar nuevos cursos a la
clase una vez que hayas seleccionado el
curso que deseas haz clic en asigna meta
de dominio elige una clase entera o son
unos cuantos estudiantes luego establece
una fecha límite para lograr la meta
recuerda que a los estudiantes les puede
tomar meses lograr el dominio de un
curso completo ya que consiste en
dominar todas las habilidades que
conforman el curso seleccionado pero no
te preocupes puedes editar o eliminar
esa meta haciendo clic en administrar en
el menú vertical
actualmente el dominio de curso está
disponible para todos los cursos con
contenido práctico completo muchos de
nuestros cursos de matemáticas
incorporan prácticas de dominio
[Música]
en el menú vertical selecciona dominio
del curso esta página muestra el
desempeño de los estudiantes mientras
trabajan para dominar las habilidades de
un curso específico primero puedes ver
el progreso de cada estudiante para
dominar el curso en su totalidad y luego
el progreso para dominar de toda la
clase luego puedes ver el dominio
relacionado con cada unidad individual
esto es útil al comienzo del año por
ejemplo cuando te enfoques en la primera
unidad al hacer clic en cualquier unidad
puedes ver otros detalles incluido el
nivel de dominio de cada habilidad
individualmente notas que que varios
estudiantes tienen dificultades con una
habilidad puedes recomendar práctica
adicional desde el reporte de progreso
hablaremos más sobre cómo asignar tareas
en otro vídeo
[Música]
cada estudiante verá su meta de dominio
de curso haciendo clic en avance en el
menú vertical de la página de
aprendizaje los estudiantes pueden hacer
clic en esa meta en cualquier momento y
seguir trabajando para lograrla incluso
utilizando khan academy desde un
dispositivo móvil
cada habilidad tiene múltiples niveles y
los estudiantes ganan puntos de energía
adicionales con cada nuevo nivel
alcanzado los estudiantes pueden
practicar de varias maneras por ejemplo
trabajando con un solo concepto a la vez
en un ejercicio o combinando diferentes
conceptos en una prueba prueba de unidad
o desafío de curso a medida que los
estudiantes obtienen las respuestas
correctas suben de nivel comenzando con
no empezado intentado y progresando a
familia y competente el nivel más alto
es dominado la única manera de alcanzar
este nivel es respondiendo correctamente
todas las preguntas relacionadas con la
habilidad en cuestión en una prueba de
unidad o desafío de curso cuando los
estudiantes no pueden avanzar o fallan
en sus respuestas el nivel de dominio
disminuye y aparece un símbolo junto al
concepto para ayudarles a identificar en
qué necesitan enfocarse más si continúan
fallando en problemas del mismo concepto
su nivel cambiará a intentado y
aparecerá un punto rojo junto a la
habilidad el dominio de las habilidad
individuales contribuye al progreso en
la unidad y en el curso en general los
estudiantes siempre pueden ver lo que
han completado y el próximo contenido en
el que deberían trabajar
[Música]
dominar un curso completo puede llevar
tiempo así que sugerimos dividir las
habilidades en fases estableciendo metas
mensuales por ejemplo o puedes hacer que
los estudiantes se enfoquen en unidades
específicas durante todo el año y luego
verificar los reportes para ver cómo
están progresando no es necesario que
asigne es la misma meta de dominio del
curso para todos los estudiantes para
diferenciar puedes proponer diferentes
cursos para cada estudiante algunos
profesores asignan una meta de dominio
de un curso anterior como una revisión
de inicio de año para obtener más
información sobre khan academy visita
nuestro centro de ayuda y consulta
nuestra sección de preguntas frecuentes
[Música]